welcome back to glamour and filtered
with me Josh Smith and today we are
joined by the star Hobson Shore and
she's McQueen but that's the card day
you are high-kicking higher than sporty
spice in there there's no pretty em
anymore
no princess no no and the only crown
jewels are the ones you're kicking
between the groin aren't they how did
you get this high kicking badass on is
what I like to know I traveled the inner
Marg
is it it's like everything she wanted to
do it just was the inner rage
it's the rage yeah it's very therapeutic
because you do you seem in the movie
that you seem very in tune with your
body I file and you seem very into your
body image what yeah you seem very like
confident in there I fell just an act
yeah trying really hard to access
because what's your journey with your
body image been like in that sense on
the crowd is called Bambi especially by
the costume department because I just
tripped up on all the shoes fell over
the whole time I'm always conscious of
my bum I always think it's too big my
sister has the same problem but like
learning to like try and accept things
about yourself and be like doing you get
one you only get you what else what else
you can't think your way out of it you
know and in a way you have to enjoy it
for what it is but I don't I don't feel
in tune with it I felt like it was
aching Norman stop
I was hobbling around the whole time for
me you've always been a very empowering
force on screen you are so fabulous but
you've kind of gone through a journey of
empowerment in your life anyway because
I read before that you were bullied at
school and how you came back from that
and all those kind of things when I was
watching the movie I thought in my head
oh my god if your younger self could see
you do that she'd be like yes Queen do
that was that thing that's ever gone for
your mind I never thought I'd be doing
actually I think I'd have loves
irrelevant thought I'd be on the stage
my whole my whole life what's been the
turning points in your own empowerment
would you say working with War Child has
changed my life
forever I think just like learning to be
okay like just trying everyday the
practice like self-care and like self
kind like self love and I think I would
summarize self love it's like sometimes
noticing the thoughts that you have
about yourself away so negative or more
negative than anyone else would be to
your face yeah and you never be that
negative to other people as you do about
yourself and it's too bizarre that we
kind of like have this this inner critic
that's when I Isis really struggle with
it and and like really doubt myself at
work and just generally and I've had to
really like nurture that part and be
like how you doing that why are you
saying that about yourself and like the
the practice of catching it and be like
okay I'm going to replace that with
something positive about myself I'm just
gonna replace it with something kind I'm
just gonna and it's literally that
simple it's like the thought and also
that thing you just said about you would
never be so harsh to your to someone
else did you out yourself I've never
actually thought about that before and
that's so true no would you ever say the
things that you said yourself you know
the only one else ever and if you were
talking to your best friend if they were
having like fears or anxiety that how
would you talk to them and I don't talk
to myself how I would talk to her
friends what do you tell yourself in
those moments what is the mantra I just
talked to myself like a would to a small
child how would I behave if like I'm
doubting myself on freaking out about
something I'm feeling super anxious I'm
just like you okay it's all cool like
remember you enough like you don't know
anything to worry about that you
literally talked to myself as a child
because I think sometimes we look for
outside sources to do that whether it's
validation through work relationships
affirmation from the outside owning
things being something more achieving
something and those things dot they're
like they're transient they come and
they go so if you depend on anything out
so it's not constant but your but your
mind could be if you if you practice it
so that's where it that basically oh my
god I'm gonna become a bit more
genetically after there because you just
touched on war child which is such an
incredible thing you've done because you
become a bit of an activist as well
which is a great thing as well can you
remember a moment when you've been
working on that that's changed your life
forever and your perception of your
South maybe I really cared before and I
so believed in what they were doing and
then when you actually go and meet them
personally talk to the families
been in that situation like I just felt
like parts that need to shift it forever
I was like I am so privileged like I'm
so lucky to live somewhere where I don't
worry about my life every day you know
like danger of my actual life like this
country is amazing it was so looked
after we have freedom we can make
choices every day to do what we want the
refugees not only have come from the
most horrific experiences but they're
also in camps that they don't live in
they're six and a half years there's
nothing to do this stuck like a prison
and they don't know when they gotta get
out can you imagine that purgatory if
not no issue car and like it just
unimaginable and then you come back and
you're like more waking up worried about
that like I can choose what I eat in the
morning and I think it makes you able to
deal with things that come up see one of
the lines I loved so much in this film
it's when you said when you're done with
your alpha male when you said that I was
like yes I meant everywhere you are a
very empowering women in your own right
when you came to a film like this did
you have any reservations about going on
to like a very male-dominated space like
I felt like it was so important even as
a supporting part of that you know the
lead female that she wasn't falling to
any tropes you know like never got saved
by the guys was capable of fighter never
got rescued you know it was never like
more pathetic than them in any way I
just wanted it had to be not some
traditional version than female action
we've seen before in a way she's kind of
amazing antidote to kind of toxic
masculinity today yeah which is what I
love about her because do you ever have
to deal with like everyday sexism less
so now but yeah God for years you know
before like the last couple of years it
was like really yeah when you were
saying you've experienced it for seven
years before there yeah what kind of
things would happen or people would say
day-to-day stuff that everyone I think
every woman's experience but also like
just in work in terms of like the
scripts you'd read you know it'd be like
she'd never be fighting out there on the
field she'd be like the woman at home
waiting to see if the man survived and
save the world for her you can talk
about oh I want to change things on a
represent women on screen and it's like
can you go into a seriously alpha male
world
that's generally regarded as like
testosterone you know and try and inject
a feminine presence that at least is
kind of able to completely take care of
herself in every way well Vanessa Kirby
you are a pair your mother loved yard
for more epic empowering videos like
this with such active people as mr.
Kirby
make sure you subscribe to the glamour
at UK channels
you